every time John introduces us to
somebody he says we're engaged I'm John
Rael and I am a skeptical filmmaker my
name is Kevin Conover and I'm a young
earth creationist I make films that
promote science critical thinking
skepticism I have a radio program where
I talk about apologetics a lot of people
don't know what apologetics is comes
from a Greek word apologia it means to
defend and I teach apologetics to
Christians school students when it comes
to evolution versus creationism
I think evolution is real and
creationism is a story it's a myth it's
a religion I believe in a six-day
creation what it says in genesis in the
bible spending a whole day handcuffed to
anyone is gonna be awkward I like trying
new things I'm kind of excited let's get
handcuffed I want to meet this guy I'm
ready to put the handcuffs on nice to
meet you John Kevin Conover that's right
John real ready to do this haven't been
arrested too often oh yeah now this will
be my first time in handcuffed Wow look
at that that's this is the real like no
flexibility there yeah be really really
close to each other one of the terms of
blasphemy for you I was Catholic so that
means I have a ton of swears in me don't
say things like blank damn it and don't
say use Jesus's name in vain let's go
okay here we go
we got into the car through the
passenger side and then crawl over to
the driver's seat because we're
handcuffed and I don't know how else to
do this guys give an exposition here the
sorry I'm not so experienced with
filmmaking okay don't crash you know if
you want to accept Christ now might be a
good time so as soon as we got in the
car we were talking about how do you get
chlorophyll if the sun's energies come
to the earth and chlorophyll is what
takes advantage of the sun's energy how
do you get the chlorophyll to evolve if
it doesn't exist yet and there's nothing
to harness the energy I was like guys
like hold on little biology card to play
and that's when we mess even pores that
know what you're asking I believe
correct me if I'm wrong is how you have
any closed membrane organism and Patra
is and reproduce itself that is what I'm
asking yeah we still don't understand
the original and we're at a point where
we understand where the first energy
capturing creature became a real urgency
but really since the process easily
unfolds in the way that we understand as
biologists I was comfortable with it I
kept announcing our engagement and I
said no we're not engaged I have a ring
I am married so when did you start
getting into filmmaking well you know
you come to LA to do the acting thing
yeah well I'm sick of commercials I'm
sick of background work so I got to
start making my own cool stuff so that's
kind of what I do now what about you
where are you taking the podcast I'm
sharing a Christian perspective on the
radio and that's what I've done my whole
life had a lot of questions about God
because I kept running on all these
people that didn't believe what I
believe and so I was like man
what you know what do I believe in and
how do I know that what I believe is
true at one point where you're like I'm
definitely an atheist I was 14 and we
asked our drama teacher like what do you
believe and she's like oh I don't really
want to discuss it but I'm an atheist
and I just started reading all these
websites and books and I'm like oh crap
that's what I am I was born with
believing parents but biblically the
argument is that it's something you have
to decide for yourself it's not
something your parents can decide for
you I think if anything could change my
perspective it would be the evidence I'm
open to having my perspective change
experience has told me that's unlikely
and then we ended up at the Natural
History Museum right when we walked in
they had a dinosaur exhibit which I was
not expecting all throughout it's
mentioning evolution and it's mentioning
millions of years how do you know that
this creature was from all the way back
then I'm questioning everything from
this evolutionary paradigm that the
creation is a museum as you can expect
it was a little frustrating there were
children there and that breaks my heart
I think it's good that kids have the
opportunity to choose we should examine
them we should look into them yeah
hypothetically in our own time but when
it comes to like you know hey here's the
stuff you need to learn kids if I had my
way we would be in a society where
Creation Museum would never occur to
somebody
I am radically opposed to what he just
said we got to the radio station and I
got my man Ross Bloch on the line is
Christianity specifically good for
culture good for society or is it a
detriment and a drag on society
obviously there's a lot of positive in
there that the Christian communities
have contributed but I don't think
there's anything within the Christianity
or any religion that you need to believe
in order you live the best you can to be
the most moral person you can the
difficulty I have is an atheist who
tells me they have a yardstick because
there is no yardstick except the
yardstick you make nobody has the
yardstick you don't have the yardstick
I don't have a yardstick you can say you
do but when it comes to real life and
applying these moral principles to our
actual interactions
politics all of the difficult things
that we deal with in life we're all at
the same spot where we have to just talk
it out and we also have Michael Shermer
who is a publisher of skeptic magazine
Michael thank you so much for taking the
time to be with us today yep the Big
Bang is a poof and it happened I mean
that's what the Big Bang is right yeah
all the 28 billion light-years across
came from absolutely nothing that's the
claim and it came with it without a
designer or purpose or anything it's
just completely I mean to me if you want
to talk about let's become a skeptic I'm
like that's crazy yeah well no this
means something different by nothing
there's always a quantum energy in the
empty space it's not really a key and
that goes all the way back to the very
big that's hard for me to understand why
you would think it makes more sense that
nothing made everything nobody is saying
that nothing made everything we're
saying we don't know therefore we don't
fill in our lack of knowledge with
whatever we want
how are you
he got there and my wife immediately
kicked into you know hospitable mode and
she's just really good that way yeah
they're serious this is the real deal
I'm not worried about the handcuffs so
much as I'm curious how our bathroom
breaks are gonna work you know that's
gonna be a little weird
oh it's real John this is Emma my
daughter Emma how's it going I'm John no
fresh shirt doesn't mean to scare you
can you say nice to meet you if you guys
don't want to be honest though I believe
murder is always wrong it emanates from
God's character so that being the case
there's a grounding there for morality
from an atheist perspective you may say
murder is wrong if I wasn't a Christian
I might say I think it's okay to murder
certain people well where do you go with
that
there's no grounding for morality it
just be your opinion versus my opinion
taking a life that is unnecessarily
taken is not okay yeah but who are you
to say that I'm a person I mean yeah but
why are you why is your opinion better
than mine because you want to kill you
would hypothetically be saying that it
is okay to kill somebody and it's not
yeah but who are you to force your
morals on the moral actually would be
you're telling him I'm wrong or
somebody's life away from ya but you're
telling me I'm wrong and you're right
in this hypothetical case yeah is it
okay to tell somebody else that they're
wrong and you're right
definitely I'm kind of morbidly curious
about how the sleeping arrangement is
gonna happen I'm a little nervous about
you know having a guy a stranger asleep
in my house you know with my wife and my
kids that's a little weird
[Music]
you've never slept with a stranger
before no that's true especially not a
stranger like a guy on the first night
you know first time I met you that's
really weird and it was actually really
comfortable at first like I was lying
back and I was just like we add up all
these pillows we have tons of pillows
and a gigantic teddy bear - yeah I was
trying really hard not to move my arm
yeah yeah because I didn't want to
bother him I didn't want to wake him up
and so I started to get stiff and I was
like oh man I can't whoa Marissa aren't
you guys gonna say a prayer or something
do you want to say a prayer I'm not
trying to force you being good
Christians I didn't think that was
necessary but I thought that was
something that people did before bedtime
well normally I pray for my kids before
we go to bed but you prevented that good
night BuzzFeed night we're doing the
breakfast handcuff thing waking up
lovely morning how are you Missy overall
when I was getting involved in getting
handcuffed to somebody who completely
disagrees with me I was thinking like
what is the point of this as I thought
more about it I think for me the big
takeaway is that it really helps me to
see the humanity of John I got to know
him as a person what was cool about this
whole experience is it's great realizing
there are people who disagree with you
about a particular subject but that's
not necessarily what defines them you
know there's so much more to a person
than just their opinion on creation and
evolution or whatever it may be
yeah it was nice coming face to face
with creationist not just because hey
you're Hugh and I'm a human it's all
good but to actually gain respect for
who he is and the way he thinks to know
that as much as as I might feel one way
about his ideology or what he thinks or
believes I can't necessarily feel that
way about him directly as a person I
mean the conversations we had I mean
there's no doubt about it I mean
I he's a softy underneath this cold
heart experiencing me come here we go
this is the big moment there we go yes
oh I feel like I can stretch praise the
Lord
[Laughter]
[Music]